Emirates at the head and Qatar are no
doubt the flagship carriers of the
Middle East with eye catching amenities
young fleets of jumbo jets along with
outstanding rememberable service these
airlines have become known for these and
continued to WoW customers however on
the financial side the situation is not
nearly as positive in fact at the hat
has been losing billions of dollars per
year for several years now in 2016
Etihad announced losses of one point
eight seven billion dollars followed by
one point five two billion dollars in
2017 and one point two eight billion
dollars in 2018
while Athiya is slowly improving Qatar
and Emirates are headed in the other
direction Qatar Airways reported loss of
69 million dollars in the fiscal year of
class 17 which ballooned up to six
hundred and thirty-nine million dollars
in the following year Emirates who is
arguably the pioneer in this space is
faring much better as they are still
profitable but they are also not in a
good financial situation in 2018 they
reported a net profit of 237 million
dollars down from 765 million dollars a
previous year a 69 percent drop but even
with the profit of 765 million dollars
their situation is a very concerning as
their revenue is almost 30 billion
dollars while their profit margin is a
mere two point five percent creating a
very small margin of error with last
year's profits that number drops to less
than 1% meanwhile flagship American
European carriers are doing better than
ever before reporting profits in the
billions of dollars in 2018 Lufthansa
was able to pull in 2.8 billion euros or
3.2 hundred billion dollars reaching
almost 10% profit margin so what
happened to thriving Middle East airline
industry well first of all Middle
Eastern Airlines have never been known
for operating Airlines but rather
building brands and the success haffley
depends on how customers view their
brands as a result they have to continue
offering money during services and
amenities to their customers regardless
of how the industry is doing recently at
the head has a limit offer and Pajama
services for business
and first classifiers and they have been
heavily cutting back on their spas and
lounges and airports but without these
things the airline is no longer at the
ad they are just another lean carrier
like American Airlines or Delta by
reducing what attracted customers to
Etihad in the first place they're
directly reducing the revenue which
leads to even more cutting and this has
created a vicious cycle of trying to
upkeep their brand name while reducing
many of their offerings which is simply
not possible this s l-- a-- ft had to
eliminate many unprofitable routes and
reduce their airline orders with airbus
in fact they canceled 42 of their Airbus
a350 orders in early 2019 but what cost
is a vicious cycle in the first place
well there's actually a different reason
for each company after Etihad they have
suffered heavy losses in their
investments upwards of 1 billion dollars
Etihad has been heavily involved in
investing space for a while but
unfortunately many of their investments
have completely collapsed two carriers
at the--at had invested in have
completely ceased operation including
Air Berlin and Jet Airways and asked for
the third investment in Alitalia well
this has just barely been kept afloat
they already declared bankruptcy in 2017
and the only reason they are still alive
is because of heavy Italian government
valve Minh
the government has really been trying to
protect the 11 thousand jobs that
Alitalia offers but this seems to be a
sinking cause as for Qatar well they
have a bunch of diplomatic issues that
have led to a blockade of Qatar Saudi
Arabia Bahrain the UAE and Egypt have
all blocked Qatar's air travel shipping
trade routes and media so not only can
qatar not fly over these countries
forcing them to create odd flight routes
and wasting jet fuel and customers time
but they can now provide routes to these
countries which is the main cause for
the almost tenfold increase in losses
for Qatar Airways and unfortunately this
issue doesn't seem to be coming to a
close anytime soon and as for Emirates
well they have been heavily affected by
increasing jet fuel prices contrary to
popular belief Dubai is not an
which nation and they have divided fuel
on the open market just like most
airlines and as they operate jumbo jets
just slight increases to fuel prices
very negatively affects them while the
crisis faced by each airline is due to a
different specific reason the underlying
problem remains the same very meager
profit margins their low profit margins
have made them prone to even small
change in the market and that's exactly
what happened any company should not be
drastically impacted by poor investment
performance and an airline as large as
Qatar should not be so dependent on one
demographic that they become vastly
unprofitable with the loss of that
demographic and for Emirates it is sad
to see that just rising fuel prices can
almost make them unprofitable but this
is an inherent flaw with all their
business models and unfortunately this
issue was going to rise sooner or later
but finally the last issue with all
these airlines is poor management a
similarity between all of these airlines
is that they're government funded and
profitability was action never a goal
instead they wanted to create a luxury
travel experience in order to paint
their countries and cities as luxury
travel destinations as a result
decreasing profits and losses have been
largely ignored by the ruling families
of these places as long as tourism was
increasing these countries and cities
didn't care about losing money on their
Airlines as they believed increased
tourism would make up for it it's now
until tourism started declining that
these countries really started to pay
attention and cut back and what better
time to start cutting back then when
tourism is already decreasing clearly
this further negatively affected the
airline's image if they had reduced
costs before tourism started declining
they may have seen less adverse results
but that is a state of these airlines
today now I'm not saying that these
airlines are going to collapse as these
countries and cities are able to fund
the losses however as you guys can see
from a business perspective it's not
looking that great and this can't be
sustained forever consequently we will
see major changes being implemented
sooner or later weather has increased
airfare or
for the decrease amenities or a
combination of both but unfortunately
taking that away would take away what
was so amazing with these Gulf carriers
in the first place better flying
experience for the same price and that
is the bleak future of Middle Eastern
Airlines but that just what I think I
personally love these airlines and
assigns me that they're going down this
path so what do you guys think make sure
to comment that down below also if you
guys thought this video did these
airlines justice the mission drop a like
so that more people can see this video
and subscribe if you would like see more
questions just like this one
lots we answered but until then I'm Hari
and I'll see you guys on the next one